it's hearty it's flavorful it literally
has everything you could want in comfort
food hi my name is Jana and today I'm
gonna be showing you how I make my mom's
out of scuttle auto-scale dough is the
Filipino rice porridge it basically has
a lot of onion and ginger and at the end
of it you get this really amazing dish
you have the crunch from the
chit-chattin and the fried garlic and
then you have that savory taste from the
ginger and the onion and the chicken
it's just amazing I wanted to make this
dish because I feel like it's not a
super known Filipino dish when I think
about the kinds of food that typical
Filipino restaurants serve they don't
usually serve out a skull though which
is crazy to me because I've grown up on
out of scale though basically my whole
life it's what my mom would make
whenever I'm sick or in the winter it's
like really good to eat cuz it just
really warms you up and it's such a
feel-good dish and I want people to know
that about out of squabbles like this
exists my favorite part about this dish
is the fried garlic you just throw in
some oil put in the minced garlic and
let it fry up and it smells so good
now we're gonna cook our ginger and
onion and cook it until the onions are
super soft I think food is a great way
to express my Filipino culture it's a
little bit kind of hard to define what
Filipino food is because so many other
cultures and so many other like groups
of people have kind of introduced their
foods and Filipinos were just kind of
like made at their own which I really
love each Filipino family has something
unique to bring to each dish and that's
what I love like every Filipino is gonna
say my mom's outer skull though is the
best or my mom's lufia is the best and
that's the beauty of it you know like
it's amazing to see what generations
have been able to do with a dish that is
definitively Filipino but at the same
time it's still unique to that family
and unique to that generation now we'll
remove it from the heat and add some
fish sauce and you're done so now we can
go ahead and garnish this baby up and
you can do it however you want this is
how my mom makes it so therefore that's
how I'm gonna make it will add some
some hard-boiled eggs some fried garlic
she chewed on and green onion I would
normally eat this dish like for dinner
but I know it's also a popular breakfast
dish actually because you have the rice
and you have the egg and it really fills
you up during the day this is the first
time that I've actually made my mom's
recipe without her so I'm actually
really proud that I was able to make it
it ended up turning out so good it's so
delicious it actually really tastes like
my mom's dish and I'm really happy and
satisfied with it I would definitely
like just keep eating it for ever not
forever but my mom would be so proud and
she is oh yes
[Music]